ah what is up reject nation john
here as you can see greg has stepped out
for about 90 minutes or so and i
saw that warren at the cosmic wonder
just dropped this video
spider-verse confirmed by sony president
huge spider-man plans revealed and i'm
like
i could wait for greg but you know what
snooze you lose
sucker but seriously don't don't tell
him i said that but anyway if you could
go ahead and subscribe click that
notification bell leave a like on this
video it would be very much appreciated
let's see what the president of
the spumpk has to say
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday we were told that we were
going to be getting some kind of a
preview for
spider-man no way this is true this is
what you said warren well they
kind of gave us a little bit of a
preview not really they teased us with a
little bit you can check out my video
from yesterday to hear more about it
but we actually got some true reveals
from the sony motion pictures president
about
the spider-verse and about the
connection that the mcu spider-verse
let's see sony picture universe of
marvel characters
and this is coming from the president
himself in an interview with
variety so it's pretty much as official
as it gets
and the crazy thing is is that in this
interview it pretty much
confirms the spider verse it pretty much
confirms it as much as you can without
straight up coming out and saying
hey toby and andrew yeah they're in this
movie they're gonna fight alongside tom
holland but there is just a ton
of information in this interview
including whether or not
tom holland spider-man is ever going to
interact with venom
carnage orbeez and craven the hunter in
fact in this interview it pretty much
tells us to expect the sinister sex
so i'll break it all up sony's been
wanting that sinister six for a long
time subscribe to my channel and to
cosmic culture and leave a comment on
the video
so if you didn't catch the news that
came out a couple of days ago
sony has officially cast aaron taylor
johnson the one and only who plays
quicksilver in the mcu
or played i guess didn't see that cast
aaron taylor johnson
as craven now this isn't craven that's
going to be in spiderman no way home
this is a craven the hunter solo film
and this article starts off by talking
about the fact that yes
they have cast him as craven but then
this article
kind of starts to mention the other
characters they start to mention
the venom movie coming out let there be
carnage they start to mention
morbius and then they start to talk
about the fact that
spider-man specifically tom holland
spider-man has yet to be involved in any
of these movies
and when they talked about that
separation the sony pictures
motion picture group president sanford
panic
said this we don't really think of our
900 characters as
the spidey verse we have a marvel
universe
the volume of characters we have you
know wait
until you see this next venom you don't
miss
spider-man that's a pretty huge
statement first of all the fact that
there are 900 different
characters in the spider-man universe
alone is pretty
insane but he also specifically mentions
a lot
which is the mcu and he specifically
states that you don't
miss spider-man in venom let there be
carnage now we know that sony wanted
spider-man
in the very first venom film or at least
they wanted peter parker to make a cameo
however according to the deal that they
had at the time marvel studios said
no because they didn't want them to
confuse the two different universes
but we know since then marvel and disney
made a new deal with sony
and from what we know it does seem like
the new deal is going to allow tom
holland spider-man to go between the
mcu and the sp umc and even the
president of marvel studios kevin feige
came out and said that spider-man was
the only
character who had the ability to travel
between different universes
so he's even hinted towards the fact
that yes this is the new deal
and that i mean yeah that that only i
feel like makes
sense i mean partly part partial partly
the words partly uh you know you have
these rights issues because sony still
owns a stake in spider-man so like
crossing universes to me just means he's
the only one
we have to share with a different studio
you know
because now they own fox they own all
the x-men and all the other
you know uh marvel properties that fox
owned so yeah i mean it seems
very reasonable to assert that basically
what they've done here is go yeah
spider-man will come back and forth
between the spider-man characters that
you guys at sony
own and he'll be over here in the mcu
and
i wouldn't be at all surprised if they
found at least some kind of workable
in-road to having more of the characters
bleed over i mean for right now it seems
like they definitely want to make
the mcu and the spunk distinct from each
other but yeah i mean
especially with the multiverses this
only makes sense and here's the kicker
panich after he said you don't miss
spider-man in the next venom film
he paused after that and then he said
it'll be
exciting if they do meet right teasing
us
once again but he also goes on to be a
lot more specific when talking about
spider-man now the article goes on to
talk about how tom holland's peter
parker
exists in the mcu and any appearance
that he might make in any other of
sony's films
like craven venom let there be carnage
or morbius might be
a little confusing and could even be
frustrating for some fans
and they start to address the fact that
it's already actually got confusing
because we saw
michael keaton's vulture in morbius but
here's the deal
panich goes on to say that he
understands the confusion and
frustration among the fans
and although of course he didn't give
any specific details it's good
did say that he expects that the tension
will
soon be resolved and that green lighting
craven a character who's also tussled
with venom in the comics fills in
another piece of that puzzle
he specifically states there actually is
a plan i think now maybe it's getting a
little more clear for people where we're
headed and i think
when no way home comes out even more
will be revealed spider verse
multiverse i mean yeah like there's a
lot of cheeky hinting here would be cool
spiderman and venom would meet someday
right like
i i almost feel like i mean you know
we go back and forth over this
spider-man news week by week
i think they know good and well and i
think they are having
fun not reveal like we're all sitting
here going it's the worst kept secret
and i feel like that's the point and
that's the fun
at this point um but yeah you know
hearing that there's actually a plan i
mean
sony has wanted to do a sinister six
team
building universe thing for a while and
you know here they also say they've got
900 other characters to work from all
sides point
to yeah no way home being this sort of
nexus
at least for the multiverse opening up
or or something like that and even just
to address the fact that like oh we
couldn't see
tom holland in this universe before it
it certainly seems like they are
gearing up to further pull down some of
these walls and i'm sure that the terms
of the sony disney deal over spider-man
are probably going to
further reveal themselves as these
movies roll out
and i mean obviously it kind of seems
like no way home is going to be what
really
opens everything up not only the
multiverse in the mcu but also this
multiverse leading into the sp umc
and the sinister six is even teased here
in this interview which i'll get to in
just a bit
but first one of the most important
parts that we have to talk about here
okay what variety listen their article
this is what they said
one of the worst kept secrets in
hollywood is that
no way home will be diving headfirst
into the multiverse
and incorporating characters from sony's
earlier spider-man movies that starred
toby maguire and andrew garfield alfred
molina
for example told variety in april that
he will be
digitally de-aged in no way home to look
like he did
as the villain doc ock at the end of
2004's spider-man 2.
now that right there oh boy
originally said now on twitter there are
a bunch of screenshots going around
of this exact same paragraph that is
edited a little differently it's
supposedly what it originally said but
then variety changed the wording and if
it's
true this is what it originally said
instead of
incorporating characters from sony's
earlier spider-man movies that starred
toby maguire and andrew garfield
it apparently said and incorporating
sony's other iterations of spider-man
starring toby maguire and andrew
garfield
that's a pretty absolute statement and
we do have the screenshots of that
and that right there is proof and it's a
precise update you know that's a
confirmation right there
but even the changed version of this
article is still a pretty big
confirmation
i mean they even mentioned toby maguire
and andrew garfield by name granted they
were talking about the earlier movies
with them in it but
they are incorporating characters from
those films into a multiverse
that's pretty much as big of a
confirmation as we can get
obviously he didn't say oh yeah and
toby's coming and andrew's gone and all
the spider-mans are getting together
but that is essentially what he just
said the only reason he actually
mentioned alfred molina would be
in the film is because we already know
that he already came out and said that
so marvel and sony gave them permission
to
say that in this interview but i mean
this is coming from the sony
pictures motion picture group president
it's as official as it can
yeah absolutely if toby mcguire and
andrew garfield aren't in the movie then
wow they really really played us because
basically we just got a confirmation
that
yeah they are they're taking characters
from their universes and bringing them
into the next spider-man film and if
they decided to do that
and not take the actual spider-man of
those universes
that might go down as one of the dumbest
decisions of all time
now we have more goods what the future
holds subversion in marvel studios
panic said this okay the great thing is
we have this
very excellent relationship with kevin
there's an incredible sandbox there to
play with
we want those mcu movies to be
absolutely huge
because that's great for us and our
marvel characters
i think that's the same thing on their
side but we have a great relationship
there's lots of opportunities i think
that are going to happen
variety would go on to ask about one of
those opportunities being finally making
a movie
about the sinister six especially with
the announcement of
craven coming to the sp umc in which
panitch said
it's tough because i think these
projects are the kind of things we have
to work on
in the dark they're not ready until
they're ready
craven is a great example because
there's a stress didn't rush it
we could have made that three plus years
ago it's just
now the script's awesome jc was the
right choice
and we found the movie star because it
was just kinsmen
dude i mean this does i mean we have to
see how these movies all turn out
because so far in the spunk we've just
had venom
but this does suggest that they really
did i don't know i mean they said their
relationship with kevin feige is great
and i do
appreciate that they acknowledge like
yeah the mcu doing well only means that
we will probably do well
if our movies are good you know by
association and i feel like perhaps
you know as long as they're going to be
sharing this character that's got to be
a pretty
close relationship with kevin feige
right so i
i would hope that the sony pictures
universe of marvel characters
is going to take on a greater caliber of
filmmaking perhaps because
in a lot of ways this is also new
territory for them and people don't
trust sony as much as they trust marvel
but this does give me hope for this
working relationship and the enthusiasm
around like yeah our universes have been
kind of divided up until this point but
now if
this next you know movie goes well we
can probably do more
it's always just suggests to me that we
can do more mixing and matching
and them working on these things in the
dark oh boy it's got to be the darkest
dark possible
and watching this other movie and
realizing that could be the perfect
casting but variety pressed a little bit
further asking about the sinister six
and after a long pause
panic chuckled and said it would be very
cool
wouldn't it and i think that that is
absolutely the plan
they're introducing so many different
characters into the sp umc oh yeah it
just makes sense
the sinister six right of course they
are then when you have no way home open
the multiverse and make it to where tom
hall and spider-man can travel to the sp
umc
it makes perfect sense that that's
what's going to happen spider-man versus
the sinister six
so pretty big reveals in this variety
article
we basically got a confirmation of the
spider-verse and the sinister six
and one of the best parts is it looks
like marvel and disney
and sony have a really great
relationship which means that that is
hard universe that has
been created that that is quite hard but
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below let me know how
excited you are for the spider-verse
and spider-man no way home be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spikes i already did
warren i like the video
greg greg did i think he was the one who
officially hit the butt
thank you all so much for watching i'm a
fan too all right woof woof
seriously though thank you warren for
the hard work that you do first and
foremost breaking these down and
you know keeping us all informed and and
like greg has said many times in these
past videos
i've seen your style grow and it's fun
to hear
more of your personality come out in
these edits and in these news reports
but um yeah man this is a
you know it's not the most mind-blowing
report out there but
it is pretty cheekily heartening
if that phrase makes any sense
whatsoever it seems like
even the people on the you know studio
side of this
are having fun teasing us and
seeing what the fans are chattering
about it does seem like i said like a
poorly kept secret um
but also that seems like the fun of it
because right now it's all possibilities
we know a couple of them are pretty
certain to be true
and with no way home i mean you know it
certainly seems as though toby maguire
and andrew garfield would have to
make an appearance at some point it just
seems like it would
make a lot of sense and it would help
bolster bringing some of their villains
over
you know but at the same time i do think
that this also is interesting because it
hints at you know perhaps there could be
future
potential for them maybe more in this
spumc
side of things you know going forward
beyond just no way home
uh so you know it's an interesting thing
because like they said nobody ever
really dies or john watts who ever said
that
uh in this universe and uh and yeah it
was especially with these multiverses
opening up it almost
seems like anybody wants to come back to
come back but yeah what do you guys
think of this news do you feel like this
is a full-on confirmation are they
messing with us
is this just nothing is this just
hollywood chicory
leave your thoughts down below and uh we
will catch you for the next one
much love and subscribe like hit the
notification bell